RFK JR says Secret Service won't provide
protection as they do for every major
presidential candidate you're literally
the poster child of why presidential
candidates need protection one Twitter
user responded on Friday FK Jr said that
he had been denied Secret Service
protection a resource provided to all
major presidential candidates since 1968
when Kennedy's father was assassinated
during his campaign after numerous
requests of the Department of Homeland
security-led panel Kennedy said that
secretary Alejandro mayorcas handed down
the official verdict telling Kennedy
that protection was not warranted at
this time I love it they say uh Secret
Service so there's context added to his
tweet on Twitter I'm sorry on X they
changed the app now like and in the App
Store it says X they say it's afforded
to Major candidates from the period of
128 days from the general election
typical turnaround time for pro former
protection requests from presidential
candidates is 14 days Kennedy said on
Twitter after 88 days of no response and
after several follow-ups by our campaign
the Biden Administration just denied our
request and here's where the story gets
fun
did you guys catch those numbers
oh God no no I I saw someone tweet about
that we don't have to talk about that do
we yeah I think we do because I don't
know RFK is being attacked by the left
for having the numbers 14 and the number
88 in his tweeting is stupid everything
is stupid all of the time
can I ask the stupid question 1488 now
for those who may not know that are
watching wouldn't be me I know what it
means what's the reference of 1488. it's
it's just two Nazi numbers
okay there's a good reason why I might
not know that then um what's amazing
about this it's not the way they say it
it's not warranted at this time setting
aside it's all like politically
manipulated um determinations oh well
when you reach this threshold we'll give
it to you what I find very concerning
about this is that announcing that he's
not getting it itself could be
misconstrued as something of a dog
whistle letting the entire general
public know he doesn't have Secret
Service protection and and it could just
be an error I mean they they uh the post
manual points out they all usually
provide it within 120 days I thought it
was a polling thing I guess I'm wrong
well it's a no-brainer thing is that
it's RFK whether RFK Junior whether or
not he even wants Secret Service
protection given um what has gone on in
the family history especially his father
because there is a conspiracy theorist
to who might have been the actual
shooter of his father uh announcing it
to the extent it's not an outright
mistake just let everybody know he's a
he's he's sitting Goose I don't want to
use hyperbolic Expressions but they let
everybody know he'll have to get his own
security fine he might be better off
with his own Super security but to let
the entire general population know RFK
Junior we're not we're not protecting
him I was just watching a documentary
about his father Robert Kennedy who have
massive respect for and I don't want to
get any of this wrong so I don't want to
tell the story like I know exactly but
he was assassinated I believe he gave a
speech he was in a hotel the Ambassador
Hotel is that where it was I'll get
mistaken on the names as well but going
through the kitchen he went through the
kitchen where he was directed to go in a
spot where he wasn't supposed to go you
have seerhan Sirhan who was the Man
convicted of went to jail uh just got
paroled or not uh paroled just did get
parole but I think Gavin knew some
overrided the parole uh but many believe
that there was someone who shot RFK in
the back close proximity because there
was contact combustion whatever that
word is meaning proximity of the weapon
and even RFK Jr himself does not believe
Sierra and sear him fired the shot
because apparently all bullets that came
from Sirhan sirhan's gun were accounted
for and they were not the ones that had
killed RFK and he RFK was told don't go
through the kitchen is that right his
security but he didn't listen to them
and he went through the kit or was it
some other thing I think it was the
other way around where they directed him
through the kitchen where he should not
have gone as far as I know is there a
real-time fact Checker here I mean I can
pull up the and then and then the theory
is that one of the theories is that it
was actually his newly appointed Secret
Service who was behind him from which he
was shot who purportedly through this
Theory might have been the one to pull
so that's why I brought it up is that
weird
you know conspiracy theory that it may
have been his own secret service or
someone in his own whoa party that did
it or early plug if anybody really wants
to know the RFK Junior RFK JFK
conspiracy theories uh Mark Robert Eric
Hundley uh America's untold stories I
mean they go into this they know it like
like an encyclopedia and I've learned it
from them but that's my understanding
I'll read a little bit here from the
wiki uh it says Kennedy planned to walk
to the ballroom after speaking on his
way to another gathering of supporters
but reporters wanted a press conference
campaign aide Fred Dutton decided that
Kennedy would forego the second
Gathering instead go through the hotel's
kitchen and Pantry area behind the
bottom to the Press area Kennedy had
welcomed contact with the public during
the campaign and people had often tried
to touch him soon after Kennedy
concluded the speech he started to exit
through the ballroom when Barry stopped
him and said no it's been changed we're
going this way Barry and Dutton began
clearing the way from Kenny to go left
through Swinging Doors to the kitchen
Corridor but he was hemmed in by the
crowd and uh and followed maitre d Hotel
Carl U Ecker through the back exit you
acted like Kennedy to the kitchen area
holding his right wrist but frequently
releasing it as Kennedy shook hands with
people whom he encountered you Wacker
and Kennedy started down a passageway
Kennedy turned to his left and shook
hands with Juan Romero just as Sirhan
Sirhan stepped down from a low tray
stacker beside the ice machine rushed
past you Ecker and repeatedly fired an
eight-shot 22 long rifle caliber 22
caliber long rifle Iver Johnson connect
55A revolver at Point Blank Range
Kennedy fell to the floor others
including George Plimpton and Grier
tried to disarm Sirhan as he continued
firing his gun in random directions five
other people were wounded so so is the
is the theory that he did shoot but
missed the theories that he did shoot
all of his bullets were accounted for uh
because he did they held his hand as
he's firing and injuring other people
and the theory is that all of the
bullets from Sierra Han Sirhan were
accounted for which means the Mortal
shot came from somewhere else and there
was an issue if you can find it there
what is it called when the when the
muzzle is pressed up against the you
know close to the body as shoots yeah
but then there's like a combustion
discharge indicating that it was done
from you know and I forget who the
Secret Service newly appointed was he
recently died
um he said RFK had
like Point Blank residue or whatever yes
and he was the one standing behind him
so he was allegedly the only one who
could have fired the the Fatal shots
through the back and and RFK Jr has come
to this determination as well he does
not believe that Sierra Han Sirhan fired
the Fatal shots there's no question that
Sierra and Sierra hadn't fired shots
yeah and all of them were accounted I
mean from a bird's eye view just
objectively the Assassin was in the
kitchen waiting for him and people right
at the last minute said hey we're gonna
change paths and move you through the
kitchen so like powder what in the hell
they just happen to move them through an
area where there was assassin so what it
sounds like based off what you're saying
I I don't know this term just saying
based off what what being told it sounds
like see your hand see her hand had
accomplices high up that were to bring
RFK into this place
maybe he wasn't even the organizer
whatever but somebody wanted RFK dead
and this guy was supposed to be the guy
to do it but he failed and then someone
had to clean up finish the job now I am
not the expert on this I have only
picked the brains of the expert Barnes
uh America's untold stories that is the
theory that all of those bullets were
accounted for they were not the Fatal
ones and to make sure it happened there
was this old a new hire like a brand new
hire the individual recently died and
that's the theory so the you know
whether or not RFK Jr even wants uh I
won't say deep State the administrative
State's uh protection I mean that might
be more dangerous than not that being
said this might be one of those
situations where it's going to be damned
if you do damned if you don't because he
doesn't get that now they make the
announcement RFK Juniors left his own
devices so you know yeah I wonder I
think it may be fair to say well
presidential candidates typically get
120 days out but don't families of
politicians who have like I wouldn't
this be a special circumstance doesn't
uh Hunter Biden obviously has C Secret
Service protection his dad's currently
the president I can understand that
but this is like a special circumstance
where I think but perhaps it's just not
procedural well who who knows but I
not announcing that it's not there is a
an act of politics uh right and denying
it is an act of politics whether or not
they even offered he says okay I'll take
yours and I'll take my own protection as
well because you know I'm looking at
Donald Trump even if they offer some
protection I'd make sure to have my own
that I can trust as well but I think
it's important to clarify too the 120
days out thing is not particularly
relevant to the story
what everyone's saying is why would you
get protection it's not 120 days out RFK
Jr did not say I am seeking a request
for a presidential candidate under the
procedural whatever he's saying I am
asking for this in general period that's
it because of his family history because
of the threats against him because of
you know uh I should say because of his
high profile status and the medius
mirrors
he's asking for it he was denied it he
thinks he he deserves it maybe he
doesn't whatever but but I think it's a
cop-out to be alike but candidates only
get it 120 days no no RFK Jr asked for
it didn't get it and complained about it
end of story he needs it it's a
no-brainer to announce it is as much of
a dog whistle as I can imagine is a dog
whistle especially from a party that
always complains about the dog whistles
um it's it's a parent it's a parent hey
guys but we've denied him Secret Service
protection Dave Smith tweeted about the
14 and the number 88 in the Tweet
because people are like oh it's like
come on dude we went to a coffee shop
and we ordered like an iced coffee and
like cookies and cream gelato and it
came out to 14.88 cents oh and like oh
are they gonna go after the ice cream
shop now because it's like a secret
thing they do they used to take the
number 13 off of uh hotels no no all
buildings like uh uh yeah you don't go
to Chicago there's no 13th floor in a
lot of these buildings hold on just
explain to me who doesn't understand
1488 with the reference to Hitler the 14
is the is the 14 Words which basically
is I forget I don't remember exactly
what the phrase is it's something it's
something about like having kids I can
read it off
on its nose it's just a normal yeah you
don't need to do though what's seven
eight eight uh H is the eighth letter of
the alphabet so eight eight you
understand yeah the eight eight I got
that's like that's like Hong Kong out of
Canada apparently yeah
I can't even believe that but it's it's
first of all by raising one oh no it's
not contractors
but it was also the clown World meme
yeah and when people would post the
videos of like the little clown Pepes
they were like Hong Kong is HH therefore
I gotta make a a correction the 14 word
slogans very racist it's not a normal
thing
I
the irony is by raising these idiotic
issues they just make them more
prevalent oh there's gonna be a lot of
people who never even understood this
that are now going to say good I'll
appropriate that and now I'm going to
use 1488 when I want to make a point I
mean to that to your point that's the
the argument or one of the best
arguments against using Marxist racial
theory in schools because you make
racists if you've got like you don't
want to have an awakened critical
conscious critical racial Consciousness
if you're trying to not look at people
based on their race and if you awaken a
critical Consciousness you end you you
by definition make people see race first
it's illiberal that those the biggest
argument again I want to go back to the
RFK thing because I want to read this in
a 2018 interview with the Washington
Post RFK Jr said he traveled to
California to meet with Sirhan in prison
and that after a relatively long
conversation details of which you would
not disclose he believed siren did not
kill his father and then a second gunman
was involved let's let's let's drive the
conspiracy theory even deeper what if
sir Han a fan of RFK was in the kitchen
and he saw whoever was setting up stop
him can you uh just Google very briefly
I think there is Sirhan Sirhan MK Ultra
type brainwashing that's alleged to have
occurred with Sirhan Sirhan
um which would explain why
uh when he was when he was going for
parole and the most recent time he got
it he was told do not invoke the
defenses that you've been using
previously which was blackout drunk I
think like I was blackout drunk and went
shooting there's a a very serious okay
good but very serious uh theory that
Sirhan Sirhan was a victim subject of MK
Ultra type brainwashing ABC News
assassin's lawyer says Sirhan Sirhan was
brainwashed a lawyer for Sirens Iran the
confessed Assassin of RFK plans to
present new evidence at a parole board
hearing suggesting that he did not act
alone was potentially brainwashed and
cannot remember anything about the 43
year old shooting
yep and and granted parole and Gavin
Newsom overrides what is it uh the
lawyer's tale has all the makings of a
great conspiracy theory if not a science
fiction Thriller akin to The Manchurian
Candidate can you understand that that
mainstream media says this this article
is what now this is uh 12 uh 12 years
old can you imagine they say it's
conspiracy theory Manchurian Candidate
as though operation MK Ultra did not
exist and did not do the things
operation Northwoods was a thing and JFK
was like nah yeah NYX is it Department
of Defense says MK Ultra it was like a I
believe no explain if you know more but
it was like a mind control program where
they put people in psychedelics and then
tell them things voluntary voluntary
psychedelics and involuntary and it
actually has a connection to Montreal
there was the Allen Memorial which is
the mental institution in Montreal where
they would test on mentally ill people
homeless people and the idea was this is
coming out of the Cold War as far as I
understand and I'm I'm free to make
mistakes on this but I'm pretty sure I
got it uh they were testing basically to
see if they could
um administer drugs to get people to
tell the truth or effectively just to
mess with their brains and and get them
to do crazy things or for or you know
disclose secrets and so it involved
involuntary intoxication like like dope
dosing up people with LSD without
telling them uh it involved
experimenting on homeless people
mentally ill people and institutions and
it's what it was this is what they were
trying to do it went on for for decades
it's I mean it was institutionalized
illegal so I pulled it up it was uh
Wikipedia says it was an illegal human
experimentation program designed and
undertaken by the US CIA intended to
develop procedures and identify drugs
that could be used during interrogations
to weaken people and force confessions
through brainwashing and psychological
torture
people out there who don't know this and
then read that bullcrap article from ABC
where they call it a conspiracy theory
it was implemented I won't say policy
programs by the government and but for
the fact that it's been disclosed or I
don't know how it was revealed um you
know and people still think it's
conspiracy theory yeah mind control it's
it's it's a conspiracy theory no you
know they were trying to do it
conspiracy theorists have a pretty good
track record at this point Unfortunately
they are more accurate than CNC
unfortunately for the U.S uh government
and for our sense of reality it's a good
thing that people are exposing nonsense
you know operation Northwoods for those
who don't know I mean everybody should
know this that was the plan to basically
stage domestic terrorist attacks blame
it on the Cuban government so they could
justify public sentiment of a war
against Cuba and it would involve uh
domestic terrorism I think it involves
shooting plane blowing up planes uh and
it involves it fabricating or or you
know falsifying terrorist attacks but
also carrying them out on uh U.S oil to
create public sentiment for a war that
they wanted to fight it sounds very
similar to I don't know something that
happened in 2001. they wanted to have
like people wearing Americans wearing
Cuban outfits like planes flying Cuban
flights flying into buildings I think
there were some they wanted mass
shootings it was they wanted to have
people run on the beaches and look like
an invading force and Kennedy said look
look John Kennedy said no and a year and
a half later they yeah you're not later
he passed on what was that let's get the
microphone
a year and a half later what what
happened happened and and but for JFK
vetoing this this made it all the way up
it's not it's not like oh some crackpot
down on the lower chain this was like
right up there JFK said no we need Shane
where's Shane at Shane Cashman yeah he
knows oh yeah he's the authority he was
he wrote this he was writing a story
about the Long Island killer serial
killer so like he knows this is his
wheelhouse he knows all this stuff
reality is Stranger Than Fiction and yet
you still have mainstream media that's
calling this conspiracy theory it's
reality conspiracy I'll tell you this if
there is anything
on this planet that makes me consider
quitting this job more than anything it
is the knowledge the fact-based
knowledge I have that everything we talk
about when it comes to news is wrong
what I mean is when a news report comes
out and says like Joe Biden did thing
like it's not true his PR people are
lying spokesperson is lying the
journalists are lying and then when it
comes to war and conflict in Ukraine the
intelligence agencies are lying and so
I'm like I know right now there's two
dudes in the CIA and they're like
hanging out in a break room Tim cast IRL
is live they're sipping their coffee and
they're laughing being like
Brands don't know what they're talking
about
you can do you can basically take the
mainstream media headline of the day and
assume that it is 100 inverted Incorrect
and it's not conspiracy theory is the
way of writing off people I think
they've recently oh sorry no the most
recent conspiracy theory was over
counting covert deaths
um now confirmed but it's just like they
they call it conspiracy theory until
they can't deny it who was it that said
it's not a question of controlling what
they know it's a question of controlling
when they know it and so it's it's a
beautiful expression I've mangled it but
the idea being eventually the truth will
come out it's not a question of denying
people uh the truth because you can't
keep the truth hidden forever it's just
a question of making sure it comes out
you know later on when they're all
fatigued and they no longer care about
the fact that they overestimated covet
deaths apparently by x amount and that
was are you referencing because they
were counting people that died with
kovid that maybe got into a motorcycle
accident as like a CO that covid had
killed them what are the rules of the
discussion here
and what capacity oh okay like there's
no regarding like uh miscalculating kova
desk if someone had it but then they
like got in a motorcycle accident they'd
say that was a covered death so that
there was a metric of died with covid
and I I think you understand that it
means quite literally what that what it
says
the rules in terms of not getting in
trouble I don't know to discuss it the
Cove is pretty cooled down now but I
just don't make claims that I don't have
evidence for it but but the whole
medical stuff is what they're actually
going after people okay well the the I
don't know whatever I'll just report
what they announced in Canadian news and
the doctor said you know we are we were
not distinguishing died with versus died
from covid and now the New York Times
came with an article basically
confirming as much saying we've
attributed x amount of deaths to died
with but first of all you can never have
a number when they were not
distinguishing between hospitalized with
versus hospitalized uh there was I think
the chief medical officer of Illinois
came out and said this like understand
we're saying with not from like they
were very clear about it
right right came out and said it and
then you got um look this is the
important distinction
the media lies often time I think this
is what Alex Jones said they will tell
you there's a bear trap and if you're
too stupid and you walk into it it's
your own fault the the you had Illinois
you had hokel you had you had
politicians telling you outright
explicitly they weren't lying they were
saying died with not from but the media
would then insinuate or write things to
make it sound a certain way yeah they
were I think they were indicating it on
on the death certificates in a way that
would allow for this confusion you
reminded me of one where when the media
one last thing go for it always go and
talk to your doctor about what's right
for you don't take medical advice from
podcaster that's if you trust your
doctor now if you come to like the black
pill Viva who do you trust anymore you
have to know a doctor to be able to
trust what they're telling you
absolutely and set a conversation
I look if I always say this like if you
if you've got a plumber and you don't
trust them you should not have that
plumber if you've got a doctor don't
trust them find one you do trust and
everybody says to me like oh all the
doctors are bad I'm like clearly not all
doctors are bad right like Trump has
doctors of course he's getting good
treatment there's celebrities and stuff
people say yeah it's expensive trust me
man maybe he's got to call West Virginia
because Maga country's got Maga doctors
and if you if if you're concerned about
certain ideas trust me the Maga doctors
know what you're talking about just find
a doctor who can answer your questions
there you go well especially once you've
lost faith because the doctor may have
said one thing which is a litmus test in
terms of reliability but I I just
remember the headline to say when the
media says something if you bet against
the media headline you'll probably be
right more often than not I don't know
if you heard about this out of Canada
when there was allegedly a protester
calling Justin Trudeau a pathetic Jew I
don't know if you heard about this no no
so it was the friends of the Simon
wiesenthal Center who put out a tweet
saying anti-Semitism is out of control
we can't tolerate this hate a protester
calling Justin Trudeau a pathetic Jew is
Justin Trudeau Jewish no we'll get there
it's even worse and then another member
of liberal government uh Garretts and
Mark Erickson puts out a tweet and says
oh we stand against anti-semitism
together and I just said not knowing
anything I said look the chances that
this person was calling Justin Trudeau a
Roman Catholic as far as I know and a
subservient political horror to Klaus
Schwab also not a Jew the chances of
that they're calling him a pathetic Jew
doesn't make any sense I'm just going to
venture that right now turns out
aggregate knowledge of the interwebs
gets out there tweaks the audio of the
recording it's either pathetic puke or
pathetic Juke because it's clearly a uke
and so the story Falls you know Falls by
the wayside but only after you know
anti-Semitism On The Rise makes
headlines on the twitterverse of
Canadian liberal thanks for watching
this clip from the Tim cat IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time